What if instead I didn't give you slope and the Y intercept, but I just gave you
2 points? Well, we remember from before we could calculate the slope from these
2. We want the rise divided by the run, the difference of the y values divided
by the difference of the x values. We can calculate the slope to be negative 3
halfs. And, again, we don't have the y intercept so, we need a different
approach to actually write our equation. We're going to use something called
point-slope form. We can have one point be x y since both variables appear in
linear equations. At least, equations that are not horizontal or vertical lines.
If we multiply both sides by the denominator x minus x 1 we can reduce this to
make 1. This is our point-slope form. We call it point slope form since we have,
well, a point and the slope. We know these two points define a line so let's use
the same process to find the equation of our line. I know the slope is negative
3 halves and then I make one of the points be xy And now I'm going to plug in
one of these points. So what do you think? Which point is best to use for x1 y1?
Should we use this point, or should we use this point. Which one do you think
would be easier to substitute in here?